how like how much do you feel like
because if people don't know you're also
uh you like and Don have cultivated a
label called generation now that has two
of the biggest superstars in hip-hop
period at the moment Jack Harlow and
little Uzi yes
um so you've obviously been
busy yeah you've been put you've also
put out records you've been you've been
listen it's like you never went anywhere
but do you feel like the Tyler album
sparked the Gangsta grills Resurgence
thousand percent
thousand percent you gotta gotta tip
your head off
to you know I saw someone say like of
all people who would have thought Tyler
the Creator of people have called a
weirdo for thus long would bring
gangster girls back to life like yeah I
mean one just the ingenious idea of him
of the the concept of him making his
album against the girls and utilizing me
the way it did and two obviously us
winning a Grammy like come on you can't
you can't deny
like Tyler had a lot to do with it and I
still think that that like
you know just even recently I saw like
Benny and Westside Gunn uh make some
references like yo we got drama out of
his executive bag like you know even
before Tyler I had I had he did the BSF
[__] I did BSF [__] I did some [__] on
guns project so you know there there
were some other projects you know out
there so I think like
um there you know clearly like as a
brand gangster girls was still strong
but I think you know the the the
response and just what Tyler's album did
like really that's we have a lot to
thank for that for sure like or even the
Jeezy snowfall like that was in the
works by the way the best Jeezy album in
I don't know what are we thinking 10
years sometime it's been it's been a
while I was like yeah we were in New
York riding around listening to that
[__] when it came out I was like God
damn cheesy back on his [__] yeah and uh
how'd that feel and then you guys are
doing the shows together yeah that was
fun that was that was dope that was a
good time so when Tyler hits you up
because obviously
you're you're you're extremely
culturally aware I don't like I feel
like some people might think oh DJ Drama
just knows what's popping in the strip
club whatever but like you know what's
up so like 100 Tyler reaches out to you
I'm sure you know how big this can be
because Igor was he huge oh yeah I mean
without question I mean
I knew I remember you know
because we started it in 2020 during the
pandemic so I was doing like Zoom
interviews and calls and I knew it was
it was coming and like you know
obviously I couldn't talk about it but I
was like yo I got some big [__] coming
no I think during our interview you like
alluded to something coming yeah but you
can talk about I couldn't talk about it
but Lake even the the session that he
came to lake lake came to the second
session um we did we did like three or
four
um his first was the second session and
when he heard the music like off top he
was like you know yeah I think he's
gonna win a Grammy for this I said it
just plain and simple clears day like
you know I think he's gonna win a Grammy
kind of like he called it are the songs
already done and then you get brought in
to like collaborate with him on like the
[__] you're gonna say yeah like what's
that process like album's done and then
you come in after or are you like in
there when he's recording any verses
like yeah for the most part it was done
I mean
Tyler's so genius and creative like he
had already when he first came up with
the idea he had taken random DJ Drama
vocals from like another project and
they put him on there placed it on like
where he thought I should talk or what
it would sound like just so he could
hear it and then like you know we we
vibed a lot like we sat in the studio
and talked and just talked music and you
know vision and things like that he told
me you know what his what the concept
and where he wanted to go and just about
life the last couple years and you know
that's literally how I like to work too
like a lot of you know what I what I
like to say on projects or you know the
direction I go I like to work off of you
know I mean I'm I feel like it's an art
in its own sense so you know I work off
of
um inspiration and then um yeah we're
going to booth and I would I would say
some [__] and play around and then he
would like kind of like be like yo like
say like I'm on a boat and I'll be like
I'm on a boat yeah he'd be like oh my
God it's [__] crazy and like you know
talk about like um having my toes out
and [__] like that so you know he was
that that was one that you know a lot of
times when I Do tapes I normally like to
do them in my own Zone but obviously it
was like collaborative very
collaborative and but you know I mean
he's a he's a one-man Army so you know
production like everything he does it
all so a lot of a lot of it he had had
done but then during the session some of
the music changed but even while I was
in there he was still kind of like
working on production and you know going
in and things like that it's crazy too
because one of you are more
underappreciated projects was the one
with Pharrell it's like kind of a cult
classic but that kind of ended up being
like
the there's no call me if you get lost
if there's no Pharrell tape yeah but
it's but you know
to me or in my travels like the way
dedication and trap or die is to certain
people the Pharrell tape is to certain
people like I've had a lot of it's like
a cult classic it is and I've had a lot
of a lot of people from
a certain like you know like hipster
kids or just like
you know not not the what you would
think the normal gangster girls listen
or like come up and like yo that
Pharrell tape changed my life like the
Pharrell gangster girls was like it was
this for me like so and artists too like
that was definitely one of those ones
and obviously that was a big inspiration
for somebody like Tyler growing up so
yeah that was that was that was a big
that was a big tape for me I mean
because you know at the time Pharrell
was already like a god you know what I'm
saying of course so when I was when he
was on a skateboard P Vibes like when
when I got that phone call like y'all I
think I you know that I think that's the
only mixtape he's ever done in his
career you know what I'm saying so for
us for me to be a part of that and when
I got that call and then just like you
know just that's that's one of those
tapes that definitely is one of the the
greatest ever like you know the way it's
put together the Zone I was in like and
[__] was incredible